21 ans plus tard la famille trudeau
retrouvera le 24 sussex la résidence
officielle du premier ministre à ottawa
c'est dans cette maison que justin a
passé son enfance il est né le jour de
noël 1971 alors que son père pierre
elliott trudeau en était à son premier
mandat comme premier ministre il y a
vécu jusqu'en 1984 sauf durant les neuf
mois du gouvernement claque
cette fois ci c'est au tour de ses
propres enfants xavier et la grèce et
adrien d'apprivoiser les hauts et les
bas de la vie ou 24 sussex mes enfants
on embarque dans une nouvelle aventure
ensemble et je peux vous dire maintenant
qui va avoir des moments difficiles pour
vous en tant qu'enfant premier ministre
mais papa sera là pour vous concilier la
vie familiale et les obligations d'un
premier ministre n'est pas toujours
facile on dit toutefois de pierre
trudeau qu'il s'occupait beaucoup de ces
enfants
malgré ces horaires chargés le premier
ministre voyageait beaucoup mais il
emmenait souvent ses fils avec lui je
pense que le fait d'avoir voyagé la
planète d'avoir vu beaucoup choses à un
jeune âge d'avoir accompagné son père
dans pleins perret est exposé à des
situations soyons honnêtes unique
ça fait de lui quelqu'un qui s'adapte
facilement à la vie pierre elliott
trudeau a marqué l'histoire canadienne
notamment par l'adoption de la loi sur
les langues officielles par la charte
des droits et libertés et par le
rapatriement de la constitution mais son
règne demeure controversée en
particulier dans l'ouest du pays
si bien que justin trudeau a dû mettre
les pendules à l'heure en plein milieu
de la campagne électorale quinze ans
jour pour jour après la mort de son père
justin trudeau a été le premier enfant à
naître dans la famille d'un premier
ministre canadien en un siècle
ben mulroney lui aussi le fils d'un
ancien premier ministre est aujourd'hui
un ami de justin trudeau et sophie
grégoire les nouveaux locataires du 24
sussex
sur twitter il recommande au nouveau
premier ministre de raser la maison pour
offrir au canada
la résidence officielle la plus verte au
monde il si philippe antoine saunier
radio canada montréal